elle a commencé avec une véritable
déclaration d'amour au maire vous
l'entendez vous êtes satisfait vous
l'avez dit les relations sont un petit
peu réchauffées avec l'exécutif donc une
relation avec la première ministre en
tout cas qui est une relation de
dialogue maintenant les déclarations
d'amour nous on les accepte toujours on
est toujours très heureux de les
recevoir je crois que dans nos vies
privées comme dans notre vie publique ce
que l'on veut sur des actes d'amour et
surtout des actes de respect et
notamment de respect de la parole de
l'État sur la partie financière et on
voit qu'il y a quand même beaucoup de
chemin à faire encore on a obtenu des
choses il faut quand même le dire c'est
un peu technique mais l'intégration de
l'année 2023 pour l'indemnisation de la
CVAE en revanche 2020 c'est pas
acceptable 2021 surtout parce que ça
repose sur une année qui une année de
chute des recettes enfin tous ces
convention technique et puis je suis pas
sûr qu'on est encore une rupture avec le
conformisme tatiste mais on y travaille
on dialogue et la MF continue de faire
son travail alors parmi les annonces en
fait par la première ministre il y a
l'idée qu'il n'y aura pas de contrats de
Cahors ça avait été dit sur tous les
tons mais alors elle dit tout de même il
va y avoir besoin d'un engagement des
collectivités et de l'État pour une
trajectoire des finances publiques
crédibles au même rythme est-ce que ça
c'est satisfaisant je vais le dire très
clairement c'est à dire que d'une part
bien sûr le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
contraintes c'est une avancée
considérable obtenue par la MF voilà
mais le principe est compté ça et
surtout la petite phrase qui a été
ajoutée après comment va-t-elle se
traduire c'est-à-dire de dire qu'il y
aura je sais plus quel est le terme
exact une équivalence ou une symétrie de
des forces sauf que nous on est on fait
déjà l'effort on vote des budgets à
l'équilibre nous sommes excédentaires
nous ne sommes pas un problème pour les
comptes et là je crois qu'il est temps
maintenant de sortir de cette fiction
d'une problématique de compte public
pour la France par les collectivités je
l'ai dit chiffres à l'appui on n'a
jamais de contre argument à la fois de
façon macroéconomique et de façon
juridique nous respectons la règle d'or
parce que si dans l'esprit de l'État
c'est de dire une trajectoire parallèle
parallèle sur quoi nous représentons de
9% toutes les collectivités confondues
de la dette publique les communes c'est
4%. donc si c'est 55 ans on est déjà en
acceptant même le principe qu'on a une
responsabilité sur la dette c'est déjà
une équitable et je rappelle que cette
dette des communes ce n'est que sur
l'investissement là où l'État emprunte
sur du fonctionnement donc faut faire
très attention il faut décrypter tout le
discours il y a des il y a une forme qui
est bien meilleure qu'avant il y a des
dispositions qui sont bien plus
respectueuses et je l'ai dit en
objectivité mais sur le principe même
d'une vision très Bercy si vous voulez
qui consiste à penser que les
collectivités peuvent être ponctionnés
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on a encore
l'inflexion nécessaire et attendu
[Musique]